i hope we can draw a line under this now
and focus on delivery okay i'm going to
stop you there 41
of people of tory mps have tonight said
that they have no confidence in boris
johnson how can you stand here and say
that is a handsome result
because
those 41 that you refer to
are equally democratic
they believe in this party they believe
in democracy
no no i'm not
it's a ballot 50 plus one is a majority
right boris did much better than that
we draw a line and we move on because
we've got two years to demonstrate in
that nation that we can deliver on the
economy we've got to deal with the
battle against the global battle against
inflation we've got to deal with the
backlog of the nhs safer streets and of
course war in europe what do you think
president zielinski will be thinking
tonight he'll be punching the air
because he knows his great ally boris
johnson will be prime minister tomorrow
morning that's what we've got to focus
on what michelle and i are doing is
focusing on skills schools family
because boris johnson has mandated us to
deliver on those things these are big
priorities for the nation your viewers
will be thinking about what are these
cabinet ministers going to do to deliver
over the next two years
we've won the vote tonight we move on
and we build this country's economy
because we have to recover from covert
and of course war in europe